hi and welcome to a very special episode
of the Simon Oxford's book club very
special because I'm joined by YouTube
legend Matthew Santoro hello thank you
very much for being here having me
well for the five people on YouTube who
aren't subscribe to you what is your
channel what's it all about uh so I make
infotainment videos top ten lists and
fact-based videos basically with the
twist of comedy talking about crazy
amazing facts from the world that we
live in and you're here we're here in
the YouTube space in London yeah because
you've got this I do yes so tell me
about the book it's the world's most
popular bathroom reader no I'm just
kidding people have been making fun and
but because like it you can read it
anywhere cuz it's just like when you
have downtime or maybe when you are
doing whatever you can just read it in
it it's it's for all ages it's for all
people and essentially what it is is
amazing like it says amazing
mind-blowing facts about the world that
we live in and it was modeled after my
youtube channel and we had a lot of fun
writing it and it was a number one
bestseller on Amazon for a week and I
I'm incredibly grateful for that so
stuff very well there yeah what made you
write the book as opposed to putting all
this in the video say uh because I
already do the video thing and Penguin
Books reached out to me and said you
want to write a book and I was actually
shocked that I hadn't thought about that
earlier because it makes perfect sense
to make a book because everybody loves
facts
everybody loves things basically
learning new things and I think it's
because humans are naturally an
inquisitive species we have a thirst for
knowledge we want to know more about why
life is the way it is why the earth the
way it is the way it is so you know we
try to answer some of those questions in
the book I mean a lot of it is I hope
you might be offended by me saying
useless facts like most until you need
them uses until yeah but you know like
there are a lot of facts in here that
aren't gonna save me in a life-or-death
situation on anything definitely not no
no but like knowing about artificial
robots and stuff I wasn't gonna save you
unless they become sentient
yeah and then you're gonna be like oh
glad I got the book cuz I know that it's
only gonna take me a week to die instead
of a day I mean I really like that that
was a point I went to make actually how
I mean effectively you know it's like
Kochan that's list of facts but you've
put them in different frameworks needs
so for the robot uprising you've been
what I've thought that it would look
like if this robot mister do it right
you know and you've checked I mean what
do you have a particular favorite format
that you've done I think I have a
favorite like chapter yeah
I have two favorite chapters the first
one is the prologue just because it's my
life story and the genesis of how I came
from being an accountant to being where
I'm at now but the other chapter is
probably the that can't be true can it
chapter because just full of things that
are gonna make you ask that question but
they're all true yeah I mean the one
that got me was the microwave uses more
power to power its clock than to
actually kick your food do you have a
favorite fact like an individual
favorite fact um Wow you know whenever I
get asked that question the first thing
that comes to my mind and I don't even
know if we put this in the book or not I
can't remember if I put it but that
jellyfish and lobsters are certain
species are biologically immortal yes I
did Pacific Lee for jellyfish is the
tour topsis door and I is the name of
the species but there's others as well
yeah I think it's might be the Medusa
jellyfish might be another one I think
so yeah but lobsters basically
theoretically can't die unless you of
course you know boil them I mean I think
my favorite in here and the one that I
really want to do is the beer mile if I
mean if I'm allowed to spoil at one
factor please yeah please the fact this
is a race where you have to race a mile
you run a Mart and then every quarter
mile you have to chug a beer and I think
there's so many there's so much
complexity in that there's there's mind
games whether you chug it's like you
know do you walk it do you sprint it
although I did think that you should
have been talking about the cheese
rolling from Gloucester have you heard
about this I have yeah I did talk about
that in a video once I put that in it's
not in the extreme sports section okay
it might be I can't remember because we
put so much in there but I know that I
absolutely talked about it on my youtube
channel Plex mental yeah well you can
tell them what it is if they don't know
yeah it's basically it's from my part of
the world which is the west country and
it's basically a bunch of people chasing
a wheel of cheese down a very steep hill
called Cooper's Hill I think it's just I
was like Gloucester and people are
wiping out and there did yeah that mean
the cheese goes about 70 miles an hour
they've had to replace the cheese with
like a phone thing now because it was
wiping people out yeah it's pretty
runaway dangerous cheese takes on a life
its own
so what how did you find the writing
process then like how different was it
formatting a video yeah well you see the
thing what was nice about it was the
book itself is a collection of kind of
the best of facts for my youtube channel
so many of them were already written but
there's so much more to the book than
that it's we got new facts that we
researched we included fan facts which
is the little gray areas and in there
and that's all things that fans
submitted and we're vetted by myself and
the co-writer Jake green and the people
at penguin and it was just it it took a
little over a year which is not bad at
all considering that you know was a huge
undertaking but yeah just the fact that
I had a an amazing team behind me and is
a blessing that I had that helped yeah I
mean the citation actually the fact that
you at the end have all of your
references a nice touch to be doing
science that's a really key fact that I
was looking at the paps so pleased that
you've of course you know
well references are important because a
people want to know more most the time
so like it's the same with my YouTube
videos you know and you see that with a
lot of educational channels you put the
sources and then if people and if that's
just that but people want to verify
things because it's like some things you
hear online are so crazy you want to be
like is that true and it's easy to just
have a source there and people can they
could also google it but either way I
mean that's would you haven't have been
a scientist do you think I know your
accountant before you were a youtuber
that's a very science-y look you know
what I don't know I think the universe
has a way of pushing in a direction you
were meant to go and I think it was
meant to be a youtuber could I have been
a scientist sure it could have been
anything I could have been an accountant
I was but yeah I'm very very thankful I
was pushing the direction I was pushed I
mean do you think you'll be an orphan
out is this the is this the first of
many books we'll see from you I hope so
yes we're already talking about
mind-blown part two so exclusive are you
know gonna run out of funds
no that's the beautiful thing is that
there's so many facts in this world and
there's always more coming there's so
many amazing sources on the internet
that you know one of my favorite is
reddit like the Tal section today I
learned if you haven't checked it out
check it out like you'll be there for
hours and hours and hours so if you ever
check out my videos and you're like I
need more that's the place to go so more
the same kind of stuff with Jeff
wanna branch out into other like fiction
like writing that comedy yeah you never
know who are your favorite authors like
what who's been an influence on your
writing I mean Gary Vaynerchuk is
someone that influenced my social media
presence but like I've read Dan Brown
I've read I read a lot of other
youtubers books actually yeah so that
was a huge inspiration to me because you
know you're joining a group of people
and in particular I think's interesting
about your book is the fact that you are
drawing content from your community from
your fans I mean is that the direction
you think we're gonna see a lot more
people doing because we're seeing
influences like yourself you have a
large following producing things but
also drawing from the community in a way
that it's a bit more like YouTube it's
collaborative I log absolutely yeah and
that's from the beginning that's the way
I designed it is I really wanted it to
be a collaborative effort and you know
just like YouTube how people leave
comments I thought well why don't I have
them submit facts yeah and then I
actually met multiple people that are in
the book and they pulled out the page
and they said page 70 I'm on that and
that's I'm Jake or whatever so that was
yeah and then you've gotten to verify it
so it's you know it's it's yeah we yeah
because we're not yeah we had to verify
yeah that's okay I mean I think that's
about all the time we have time for cool
but thank you so much for being on the
channel if you are interested in facts
like me because I love this I should
point out thank you thank you check out
this book it's available everywhere
Amazon iTunes audible I got an audiobook
everything how did you find doing the
audio but by the way that's another
interview all time it was a long process
it's but you know what it was very
rewarding because I've had multiple
visually impaired or blind fans that
said thank you for making an audio books
like I can't I couldn't there's no
Braille version so yeah that's awesome
oh very much thank you guys yeah thank
you thank you